[Music]
on today's show we talk about tigers and
parenting and crying it out and cancer
morning routines why wilco is not that
great johnny cash jocko and more it's
ama number three on our 200th episode
stay tuned
[Music]
what is up this is john with the dr john
deloney show
man if y'all could only hear the
business kelly was just giving me before
the show went off holy smokes
i've got enough makeup on for like a
small army of people otherwise you can
see how red my face is because you hurt
my feelings so bad
that's so not true you don't have any
feelings okay that's me over the last
few years you've just ground them off
and by the way i said last few years
today it's the 200th show
200.
we all like when we were at that
restaurant talking about this show
before we kicked it off we all were like
i thought we could get 30 out of this
thing hey this is the dr john dolan show
in case you're new to this
thing glad you're here hey this is a
special it's our third ama we have a
packed house out here
uh there's two people out there in the
audience that's a packed house for us
we're excited
um i hope y'all are you aren't cutting
work or something like that it's good to
see y'all it's awesome
um so hey we got an ama we put a uh call
out on the internets to send in some
questions and you all sent in a
bajillion of them
and so we'll go through them but first
can we celebrate 200 shows what do we
celebrate
i was waiting for confetti to fall down
from the sky but i know that would have
been a lot of extra work james and so
we'll have that we did get you a cake
for the the year anniversary so for the
200's we'll just do like a pretend
cheers through the glass
wow i expected gifts to be honest yeah i
did too it's cool though
um james isn't that kind of producer the
one that quote unquote loves his talent
or uh she made gifts from youtube from
you
oh it would have been cool for a heads
up just that this was the 200th show
just before three and a half seconds ago
before we go live kelly's like you suck
i hate you it's the tune of the show
make sure everybody knows and we're live
you didn't say that you didn't tell me
about doing a show you said the other
things but not that right james said the
thing about the two other show i told
you to
get it together and let's get going
oh man
this is gonna be great people have
already just rolled off of this thing
it's cool
well here we are ama
should we get right into this
do i have to do these in order james
yeah let's do them in order and for the
unaccustomed to explain what ama stands
for the unaccustomed
that's a very big word i like that
you've been on the show a lot that's
cool
um ama ask me anything people want to
know um i talk a lot about the advice
and here's my recommendations and here's
how we're walking alongside people who
are struggling with various challenges
and then people dig in and want to know
what's going on in my life like how do i
actually live this stuff out and what do
i eat what do i
kind of workout program all that kind of
stuff so what do i actually do so
um i know some of these questions are
coming and i know you'll have some off
the grid questions you'll put in here um
so here let's just get into it so
some people wrote questions that were
for me
and i guess silly and then other people
wrote questions like
broader
just question questions so
um first question as far as raising kids
time in or time out
what do y'all think
this is your show brother i know but i
like to set you all up because if you'll
answer it right that's great and if you
answer it wrong i can mock you because i
don't know who wrote this i think it's
different per kid per child
very good switzerland
yeah
how's it different well like for
instance um
when we adopted our kids we would not
have done time out because they needed
to learn to be with us but there was
times when
yes you have to be in the room you have
to stay here you know you're going to do
this thing but it also depends on the
situation sometimes they need to be
removed from a situation
especially toddlers and stuff they need
to be chilled out for a minute so pretty
cool i don't think it's a black and
white issue
so here's my take on it so and we'll
just let james stay silent we're he
spends most of his time in his heart and
mind
um so
i
i'm not a fan of time in or timeout but
i believe in time in timeout here's what
i mean by that
time and time out
i think weaponizes relationships meaning
if i
if my kid does something so let's just
say my son hank he
i don't know swears at me at the kitchen
table and i say get away from me
he's done a thing
and then i punished him by removing him
from my presence
i have made the relationship our
interaction
the punishment
for his action
so in a weird way it holds
my
love it holds my connection hostage that
he is always working for connection with
me
now
if if you weaponize relationship it
doesn't make any sense to a child's
brain
because it's gonna make it they're gonna
up the ante they're gonna go back over
the top
so
my child though can opt out
and that's where i think time and time
out is effective
not by me saying you get out of here or
you can't be in this room right now
but
when you do the work and we've talked
about this a million times on the show
when you do the work up front and say
here's who we are we treat each other
with respect we treat each other with
dignity we
fill in the blood we do these things as
a family this is who we are
and then he swears at me at dinner
then he is opted out of
our relationships so he is the one who
by his actions have taken himself out
and i want him to own that so i'm not
going to weaponize my relationship i'm
going to put it as i'm going to put it
on him as a choice
if you choose to be with us this is how
we all are we all agreed on this
or i'm the parent i said this is how
we're going to be
if you choose to swear the table you are
choosing to leave and i also make it
really clear the house doesn't function
well without you we want you here
and so i choose to be sad when you opt
out
because it breaks my heart i want you
here i want you around you're a you're a
full member of this family but when you
do things that opt you out
you do things that opt you out right so
kids are so wired for connection
this helps their behaviors in a direct
way because
it's the exact opposite of what they
want he he may cuss at me at the table
because he's trying to connect with me
he's trying to get a rise up he's trying
to get attention from he's trying to get
me to see him and he may do great things
to get my attention he may do loud
things may do things that are going to
cause trouble he's trying to get my
connection my attention trying to
connect
and if he understands that his actions
disconnect him from us
then man he's coming back
he's going to begin to lean into i want
to be in community here not out of
community and this is almost every
single kid
if you remember that your kids are wired
for connection man i was gonna lean into
that so i don't know that sounds like
mumbo jumbo
james is already asleep over there no i
think it's great i am not whatever all
right number two
cry it out yes or no
cried out yes or no
all right here's what i think about that
i think there's
let's let's break this up one is newborn
so
read psja by the way let's like the i
think it's a pre-operational stage let's
go back and review all that psja
um
so there's let's say one two zero to one
zero to five months old six months old
nine months old and then one and a half
to two years old
so backing all the way out of here
think how babies brains are wired
they're running on ancient tech and they
just got dropped into the 21st century
okay
so the brain that you're that a baby has
let's say a newborn one month one week
old one month old
is not wired for a 3 500 square foot
home or a 2 500 square foot home with
its own bedroom and its own bathroom and
a door that locks
and
it's not born in a culture that says
too much touch harmed a baby which was a
prevailing wisdom for about 150 years
100 years
um that they were dropped into a world
where there's no adults around
at all
and there's no extended relatives around
at all that's not the brain that they
have in their heads the brain they have
in their heads is one where there's
always adults around there's always
some sort of extended cousins and aunts
and uncles there's a tribe there's a
community
and so this idea that you could even
take a child and put them far enough
away where you could shut a door and
they just cry until it doesn't bother
you anymore or i could turn the volume
up on my tv that's not their their brain
isn't right for that when an infant when
a newborn is crying
they are just screaming for like we just
talk about connection so the idea that a
baby could ever even be far enough away
to just quote unquote cry it out as
preposterous it's not it's not
evolutionarily correct right
and so
now we drop ourselves in the 21st
century and i'll include i'll just speak
for myself exhausted i got shows i gotta
watch i gotta get to bed
i got a
i'm working a full-time job let's say my
wife's not but let's say she's working a
full-time job we got this and this we
got sports athletics so now
we have a lifestyle that's not attuned
to a child's brain
and we're
we're so obsessed with independence with
quote unquote you being the master of
your world which is true
you've got to take ownership of your
decisions that's all true but we pass
that along to little babies and so this
is where i hear this
um that we're going to teach them to
self-soothe we're going to teach them
how to
um learn that they're crying
they need to be their own they need to
they need to
you know get stronger right they need to
learn how to flex
and that's where we've gotten sideways
and so babies learn from watching and
absorbing the adults in their lives not
quote-unquote just figuring it out
they're a tangled mass of
just
responsive brain cells
touch responsiveness lacking these basic
things cause trauma in the young baby's
brain
so when they feel
that a caregiver is gone
trauma that registers there is
the single most devastating trauma a
infant can can absorb other than other
than like you know being physically
assaulted right
little babies quit crying not because
they get better or because they are
self-soothing but because their bodies
just quit they just give up
and so what i always want to point
people when they ask that quite like
raising babies is about creating an
anchor point not teaching them to quit
and
once you have a one and a half year old
you know i mean i think it's about 14
months let's go back and look at the
research on it but one and a half two
years
a child begins to understand that they
aren't the world
that they are a participant in the world
and that's when they start learning
about object permanence when that door
shuts my mom doesn't disappear she's
just in that next room an infant thinks
when the when
mom leaves her sight that's why
peekaboo's so fun when my mom leaves her
sight mom has disappeared mama's gone
and then mom pops back up and it's like
oh look at that she's back
that's why a two-year-old doesn't think
that games is fun because they know
mom's just right there
then that's when you can slowly start to
see you know you get a one-year-old one
half-year-old two-year-old a kid who
slowly starts to weaponize that
relationship and i say weaponized
they're still young they're still
wanting connection for everything but
that's where a kid would say okay you
need to go to bed and they
crying for connection that's that terror
scream turns into whining that terror
turns into manipulation that terror
turns into
um and i say manipulation not like a
grown-up does but like a two-year-old
just wants more mom or wants more dad or
whatever
so i've got less of a problem when
they're one and a half two
crying it out two hours that's insane
but crying it out um
the kid is crying they're gonna they're
gonna cry until they settle themselves
out go asleep but it is age dependent i
think so to answer your question i think
it's insane i think it's i think it's
devastating to do it with a newborn i
just do
um and again this isn't about shame it's
about trying new things i'll leave it at
that maternal stress is powerful so i
think it it it sometimes we have to look
at an entire
remodeling of our ecosystem of our homes
of how we're going to raise people all
that stuff
and a one and a half year old has to
know they cannot control our home
they don't have the power to cry and
everyone jumps that they do have to go
to bed and that there's going to be some
discomfort as they're learning to go to
bed by themselves
and so it is a balance there
um i
i tend to fall on fall your gut
you know when your kid is crossed over
and it it's that uncomfortable feeling
there's something not right here
versus that kid's just whining like my
kids have seven different cries i and
you just get to know them all um that's
the prevailing wisdom follow your gut on
that one and if you've got a child who
can't stop crying or won't stop crying
or have some physical elements then
obviously check with your daughter your
doctor every time
um
but i think it's different for newborns
than it is for
you know toddlers um and i think the
whole idea of crying it out toughens
your kid up is nuts because it doesn't
it traumatizes them it makes them weaker
that's a better way to say it
um it does make them
realize hey there's nothing i can do to
reconnect with my mom or my dad they've
left me i'm gone now and so my body's
just gonna shut down it's gonna go to
neutral because that's its only option
right
um
i'm sure that will cause some drama on
the internets but that's my thought on
the cryos what do you think y'all are
all parents i have some thoughts that
i'll keep to myself except that uh one
funny
joke that i heard it wasn't actually a
joke it was for real my buddy kyle who
you know yeah yeah uh we were talking
about it and i was like have you tried
crowning it out because his kids were
having trouble sleeping and he said dude
i cried out every night
[Laughter]
so what are your thoughts you think i'm
crazy
no i don't think you're crazy i i didn't
know the science um
i don't remember when we did do cry out
with our kids i don't remember
what age they were
or what kind of limits we set on how
long we went or whatever but it worked
well for all our kids and they as as
like one month olds i don't remember the
age i actually text my wife just to see
because i was curious as you were
talking about it but no both blocked it
out yeah yeah but i mean we had you know
we had
limits and everything but it worked and
they
they loved you know they learned to
sleep and they love sleeping now and it
to me like having good
having good sleep habits really sets up
the whole family for
success in a lot of ways but there's a
lot of nuance to it well i think it's
james you and i were talking about this
earlier i think
if a kid goes to bed and mom and dad are
saying sleep is very important and we
got to go to bed and we got to get a
full night's sleep et cetera
and then the kid can hear the tv on
until midnight
the kid is getting a disconnect between
mom and dad are doing and what they are
professing
and of course we're adults we're not
supposed to live like kids do etcetera
but there is a a cognitive dissonance
with a young child they feel that what's
being said what i'm being made to do is
different than what's actually happening
and that's again that's a that's an
older child that's not a one month old
that's a maybe a two-year-old or a
three-year-old why do y'all get to stay
up et cetera because we're grown-ups
that's what happens i think for me it
came down to
when i was letting my kids cry cry cry
it was
it was getting in the way of my
perceived lifestyle which i think that's
what adults nowadays need to re-examine
is my lifestyle conducive to
am i trying to do everything i'm trying
to still go out and hang out with my
bros and do my thing and make watch my
shows and have a child that's where
you're gonna get crossways and there's
also the flip side of like co-sleeping
and just parents letting their kids keep
them up all night and just it ruins the
whole family
dynamic everything yes and there's two
two slides you steal sleep from your
kids all right
um and that's the thing yeah it
and some people have to work three jobs
you know i don't i don't have that
luxury i gotta go to bed right and
that's that's one of the that's the
modern world that we're in right now um
so again this isn't about shame but
especially with infants and newborns i'm
not a fan of cried out there's some
great research on that that's just
devastating to read it's hard
um and
like james says man you have to set good
strong sleep boundaries and limits and
so i'm sure we'll get a million more
questions about that but that's good all
right let's do another one
um
new routine what's is that probably
morning routine you guess
yeah has your morning routine changed
yeah so like this is my usher moment
it's my confession
dude my routine like collapsed i it
didn't collapse i allowed it to i
checked out of it um
in the last like several months i've
been on the road all over the country i
got a great routine when i'm on the road
but not so much when i'm at home and
then writing the book i've been working
20 hour days for
man maybe a month or two it's been a
it's been a trek and so i guess
confession one is
i didn't stick to the routine
and then when i don't stick to the
routine i get unwieldy and then when i
meaning my diet goes to crap i don't
exercise this regularly and then my
writing isn't as good and that gets me
frustrated and then my work isn't as
good and that gets me frustrated and
then and then it just has a cascade
so about two weeks ago man i locked it
back in had to really dial back up the
routine
and then slowly work to our
where i am back now so
um yes i got out my pocket but i have it
here i think i do maybe i put on my desk
um i still have my i still have my
little card my note card that i write
down um i do it the night before now
here's tomorrow's workout what that's
gonna be and then here's tomorrow i look
at my calendar
and see what i've got going on tomorrow
and i can just make a quick checklist
and that gets all my thoughts out of my
head
and then at night i try to make sure
that i've got my plan for the next day
before i start my going to bed routine
and then i get up man i get up pretty
early still get up about five five
fifteen
and
do my coffee or my tea and then
exercise and then i got my i brought my
this is my gratitude journal that i do
almost every day
and then this one's new this year james
kelly this is my uh
i have something about y'all in here
it's my stories journal
i just have these looping
thoughts that just stay in there and
stay in there and stay in there and stay
in there and there it's called
rumination john i was about to say it's
just ruminating over and over oh my
imaginary conversations when i see kelly
next i'm gonna just tell her you better
just wait until i and i never say it
it's just a waste of my time but i start
rumening and ruining so this it or the
yeah you're the worst dad ever or
whatever so i wake up in the morning
or uh as i'm getting going through my
morning and i have this out and i'll
just write down
um
you're the worst dad ever that's like a
thought in my head or you really screwed
it up last night when you should have
gone to bed earlier i write these
stories down and that way i can get
arm's length and i can look at them and
just say is this true or not
and if it's not true then i can just
draw a line through it and if it is true
then i can solve it and then move on
jacob calls it detachment uh michael
singer calls it mindfulness it's just
looking at my thoughts
and not letting him take over my body
and saying is this thought true and then
i can just move on from it so i had this
with me
still meditate several times a week um
not as much as i should i gotta get back
into doing that um still i haven't still
exercised regularly and then man i had
to get the cold tub back out
it's so great
it's so great good people 99 bucks at
tractor supply it's just like a
bucket
fill it with water and just set it
outside it's not a bucket actually it's
like a trough fill with water and just
let the cold air do its thing this
winter and then just go sit in it three
to five minutes in the morning
it is incredible have you ever done that
yeah i won't do that will you
i've done cold showers yeah yeah um a
lot of times i'll take a warm shower and
then
i'll turn it to cold right before i get
out just to make you angry yeah just to
start it off with a really pissy day
that's awesome i also did this um
so
i got with dr gus vickery i'm gonna have
him on the show and he's gonna go
through my my blood work and my genetic
stuff he i finally just bit the bullet
and did a full panel this guy was asking
me questions
i have a genetic trait they call the
cookie jar jean
that says you have a very difficult time
it's wired in you that when the package
is open
you're going to eat it all
and so you can you can white knuckle it
you can willpower your way through it in
seasons that is not a strategy and so he
said just looking at your genetics the
strategy for you and let's say gummy
candy is never prevention don't have
them in your home don't have them in
your bag that's why my serial killer
wife can buy a bag of gummy candy and
just have one
one like every few days
like a
murderer she's in one of your podcasts i
bet i don't know how you can do that you
can do that but she does i can't like
he's like said that's in your genes and
they have like a name for it anyway
it was fascinating but um got a bunch of
new supplements and stuff but it really
got back
got me back to man i got gotta take care
of my diet i got to
really be intentional about exercising
every single day and i am
doing more strength training let's see
how strong i can get and now that i'm
old
and
man the the
temperatures the saunas and the cold
tubs man i need this show to be better
so we can buy one of those fancy cold
tubs things are amazing and like uh
those saunas would be great too
i guess the cold tub would just be for
when it's not winter time and you want
to do the same thing right yeah you can
put it inside i mean i got in this
morning it was a little bit sketchy
there's some
some i mean i don't know like cody's
drinking from it or something i don't
know it wouldn't probably this the most
hygienic thing in the world but it's
cool that's cool i don't know um so
that's the new routine um what i'm
focusing more on when it comes to teen
is my evening routine and my wife and i
actually had a long discussion about
this this weekend talking about
i found myself sitting in the driveway
for 10 or 15 minutes when i get home i
just sit there and i may scroll social
media i may just listen to the song on
the radio but it's almost a gearing up
for
round two like i've
gone to work and or i mean i did my
morning routine that's run one round two
is going to work and then now round
three like
okay that's back into debt
and i i don't want that she doesn't want
like i want that to be the place i can't
wait to get to because i can just go
and so we've done several things we've
set up one of which um will just be a
a routine a tradition that when i get
home we're all there when she gets home
then we're just gonna all pause for a
minute me and the little ones even if
they're in the middle of a thing where
everyone's gonna stop for a few minutes
just acknowledge each other as humans
and it may be that i need to go exercise
15 minutes and just kind of get the
shake-offs uh maybe that we're going to
have a dance party for phoenix but it's
just something about to mark
we're all here and something i can lean
into and look forward to
um maybe having tea we all have together
whatever that looks like um but there's
something about an evening routine that
is gonna make coming home not a
another assignment but a place of rest
and a place of um rejuvenation not a
place of
more shame and not doing great so
yeah
um so yeah that's it on the routine kind
of being lame i will say this
get a routine
mine has gotten streamlined this time
last year was really complicated it's
gotten more streamlined wake up early do
my journaling exercise do the cold
variations and make sure i'm spending
quality time with the humans in my life
and that's about it
get one and stick with it and if your
life begins to make your
morning routine impractical
usually it's your life that's the
challenge not your routine all right
we'll be right back on the dr john
dillon show
[Music]
hey what's up this is john let's talk
about a good night's sleep
it's important for your physical health
your mental health your sanity you name
it if you're not sleeping good the first
question i want you to ask yourself is
do i need a new mattress and here's how
you tell if you're tossing and turning
all night because you can't get
comfortable if you woke up at night and
you're all hot
right or if in the morning your back
hurts if you have any of these issues
you may need to check out a new mattress
if you're ready for a new mattress i
want you to check out dream cloud it's
the mattress i own and you'll love it
and they're currently running their
biggest offer ever 400 bucks in
accessories plus an additional 250
discount only for delony listeners
that's a total of about 650 dollars in
accessories and savings visit
dreamcloudsleep.com slashdaloni or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get a new mattress today and
enjoy 650 bucks in savings that's
dreamcloudsleep.com promo code
d-e-l-o-n-y good night
we're back and the audience is still
going crazy out there
both of them man it's a wild night house
out there
a little bit of the old
i see it's cool man way to go everybody
wow showing up to the lobby bonkers all
right so we're doing the ama ask me
anything this is episode 200.
we made it kids 11 more years we'll have
a thousand
is that right it's about 100 a year
oh we're still doing this in 11 years
we've done something tragically wrong
with our careers right
especially you two
i could see if they won't even have
podcasts in 11 years they're gonna i
don't know just teleportation devices
this show will be a hologram that you
can watch yeah in the metaverse or
whatever that thing is ugh yeah that
gives me hemorrhoids all right so
number four favorite distressing junk
food
just same old burgers and fries and
gummies and marshmallows
caramel
what else ice cream
uh cheap chinese food
i can
okay can i tell you an awesome story
though
i don't call this junk food but it's not
good for you is there a difference there
unhealthy food and junk food yesterday i
left work early i was just having a
rough day and i just called my wife's
son i go pick up hank from school and i
met him in the line i picked him up and
he's like hey dad it's great to see you
and i said
how about me and you go eat some trash
and he's a small rebate and goes oh yeah
and we went to like a local restaurant
and just eat garbage just to get like
a burger and
just nonsense it was closed we ended up
going to the gas station and just
getting candy it was just it was awful
it was absurd
um but
so there's trash food
so this happened guys this is incredible
i was in san antonio
a few days ago and
did an event there i just drove downtown
until i found the most authentic-looking
mexican food place i've been missing
texas mexican food so bad
and i just saw a place and i thought
this is 50 50. this goes really bad for
me or 50 50. it's incredible so i went
in i got a they set me in the back
because i guess i looked a little bit
creepy i sat in the back of the
restaurant all by myself and i was
trying to finish these chapter edits
some writing back there with the old
with my computer
dude the food they brought
like if jesus was a burrito man it was
unbelievable how good it was queso
everything ev all of it man
and then i'm just eating and i'm being
over the top it's i couldn't believe how
delicious this food was like my soul was
coming back together like it's been in
pieces since i lived in nashville it was
slowly coming back together i felt it
reforming like a like a like a
transformer a voltron remember how they
made anyway
and then this man comes over his name is
armando
and he had like a u.s marine corps shirt
on older gentleman
and he said excuse me are you uh
dr john deloney
and i was like i say what
yes
he said hey that's my family over there
we you looked familiar and so we just
spent the last 30 minutes looking you up
on the internet to see who you were
and i couldn't believe it like i'm a
huge fan of yours and dave's and he's
like
you changed my life i was like i didn't
do anything dude i'm just like to have a
podcast i'm just sitting here in the
back eating queso
and he dude and then he took my receipt
off my table and was like
because of you all i'm able to bless
other people and so this would be my
like it was a whole thing man and then
went over and sat with their family
but two important things from that
number one
we took pictures and i'll never see him
again like i don't i don't have any
contact information it was amazing it
was incredible
so number one like man the reach of this
thing is bonkers to me
and the people who were just in
random san antonio texas or wherever
the second thing that's really important
is
i can never do drugs
anywhere
because man
if i would had been in the back just
just like snorting coke off the table or
doing something crazy
and they would have been like oh we know
that guy there's nowhere to hide there's
nowhere to hide i like that that's the
reason you can't do drugs yeah
otherwise you'd be totally cool to just
i i mean listen
i wasn't gonna but man
just a hole-in-the-wall mexican food
restaurant in the middle of nowhere
texas
the eyes of texas are upon us man so
anyway armand that was like one of the
most the coolest can i tell you
something else that happened
at that same event
i
walk on the stage in the in this hotel
just doing a a talk for a group
dude they start the walk-up music was
old metallica
blaring i can feel it in my chest and i
looked at the sound guy i was like
yes yeah i felt like i was an mma
fighter like this is awesome
then i got done with the talk and he
started blaring master of puppets and
then their little like their gift bag
they gave me
two rad metallica shirts in them
what a gift you two suckers were just
here turning knobs on the radio it was
awesome that wasn't very cool of me
that i just did just now but dude
there's some great people out in the
universe
i love how this question about junk food
got real sentimental and serious
well i i couldn't wait to get to i
actually moved to flight so i could go
get some mexican food because i was
gonna get there after dinner um and i'm
glad i didn't man it was amazing
oh man so next question have you
recovered from the astros losing the
world series
i don't appreciate that question
the answer is yes i've recovered i'm
fine
you know what i love james and kelly
you ever notice other grown-ups
when you go to a ball game and there's a
grown man wearing a shirt with another
grown man's name on the back of it that
always strikes me as the heebie-jeebies
we talked about this on the show because
we were talking about signatures have we
talked about that yeah that always just
makes me a little bit hit so i say all
that to say i'm a huge stroze fan my
buddy mike who i love sent me like me
and hank he went to the games mike and
tom they went to games they sent me some
world series shirts they're great here's
what i think happened i think the astros
looked at the braves and they said look
we can destroy these poor kids let's
give atlanta something to talk about
let's give them something
it's i think they tank to the series on
behalf of atlanta because that's the
kind of people houstonians are they're
giving and they're kind so yes i have
recovered from losing the world series
because i think the loss was an
altruistic one i think it was a gift and
it is harder to win when you don't cheat
so that's
that is the second world series they've
lost after they aren't allowed to cheat
i'm just saying guys i'm just saying
kelly you don't look convinced
no you live in a fantasy world
agreed and
not mutually exclusive
so yes what are some new books i've read
oh man um
i don't i've read a bunch of new books
okay okay here's some of my favorite
books all right i wrote them down
this book was by john valiant and the
book is called the tiger true story of
vengeance and survival
it may be
maybe in the top 10 books of all time
it was extraordinary it's a book about
the tiger
and it's a geopolitical book about
russia where russia connects with china
and life there and it also is the story
of a particular tiger that seeks
vengeance on somebody
it is a tightly woven masterpiece i
listened to this book i discovered
audiobooks this year man i thought i
read a lot before now i it's awesome i'm
mowing through books this year i love it
this
story like i would knock off work a
little bit earlier so i'd get in the
truck and go listen or i would
just mow a little bit longer so i could
keep listening this book was incredible
another great book i read it wasn't
quite that good the tiger true story of
vengeance and survival i recommend
everybody read it's a masterpiece
um another great book was called
ravenous by otto warburg
um
oh ravenous ottawa warburg and the
cancer diet it's written by sam apple
apple the book's called ravenous
it's a phenomenal book about
the nazi germany obsession with curing
cancer
as germany became more affluent and as
they started having more of the quote
unquote good life
cancer came with him
this disease of excess
and warburg is a famous scientist it's
on with cell respiration and cancer and
it's a whole thing you can read about it
um he was the kind of the hero of the
world the greatest scientist in the
world but also
was then fell out of favor now
in many ways he's back
but he was a
gay
jew
protected by the nazis because he was
the most
um
he was the person most likely to solve
this cancer problem
and so it's this
weird moment in history
where nazi germany is protecting like
they have this whole this whole world
where
jewish people are inferior
yet they protected this guy where
members of the gay community were
inferior but they protected this guy and
his partner
and then you've got
warburg who is taking money from
these
groups from these folks
working in the middle of
germany when everything around all the
the jewish people are being slaughtered
and it is the most
it's like reads like a like a
i don't know like one of your podcasts
like you don't know what's gonna happen
i found myself i read when i was camping
i found myself i wasn't able to stop
reading i'd go outside and read it in
the dark it was so good
um and has a lot of cool science stuff
it is a science nerdy book but man it's
pretty rad
and then for
i brought this dude this guy
if you've got young people in your life
or if you're a grown-up like me who
loves reading these books
his name is sj dollstrom now i talked
about this i talked about last time
he's written several books the book the
wild or good is the character here and
it's multiple series i think what book
is this this is book
number seven so it's up to seven now
this one's called cowboy hood
the one before blackrock brothers these
are
extraordinary and there's a series of
them so you got a young kid buy all
seven of them
incredible if you're an adult and you
want to read fiction that's good
um but it's also at night time and you
don't want to read like science at night
because i think that's ridiculous get
your head all all or you don't read the
news at night time because your brain's
gonna be like oh we're all gonna die if
you want some great fiction about
getting outside
um i know sj dollstrom man he's a great
human being um we've had some fun
adventures together but he writes books
to inspire kids to get back outside
to put the screens down and live a more
screen free life than they otherwise
would and these books are just
masterpieces my two favorites thus far
are blackrock brothers and cowboy hood
wow they're so good my kids love them
but i love them and there's a great
range and he also
man he's got some good stuff in there
for the parents too just they're
fabulous books man um and then my wife's
book came out
this year lord she wrote a prayer book
for teachers if you're a teacher you can
get on the instagram to follow her and
it's it's a
it's a pretty rad book too
um those are the books i've read any
books you have read that are great
i know james you're not a big reader
you're more of just a
i was going to say that's not true but
none come to mind right now
well played kelly i read at your
insistence a lot of fiction now
because
i quit having to read things that were
so dark yes but one that i had picked up
early on that's not fiction um
non-fiction as some call it
that i picked up
for all the listeners out there kelly
was in honors classes that's
that's what i was thank you very much
but um
grit by tammy duckworth yeah and i i
for some reason or another has accepted
it i think so i don't think it's tammy
is it tammy i don't i'm pretty sure okay
go ahead though but that's a great book
yeah it's a fantastic book just talking
about how it's not always i mean talent
and smarts are one thing but how it's
that whole idea of just grit sticking
with something and and how that really
changes
you know you how you learn things how
you stick with
how you change your life how people that
are the best at what they do how many
hours oh yeah they have to put in you
know they may not be the one with the
most natural talent or the most natural
ability but the hours you put in
changes everything and how they deal
with failure and get back up and get
back up and use it as a learning process
as a zone that they get in and she talks
about everything from athletes to
musicians to business leaders it's not
just you know art you know artsy people
it's for anyone and it's really really
good it's also for i got a lot of that
book
for dads and moms and brothers like how
to just do better at life and you got to
keep showing up and keep showing up i
don't know i it's a fabulous book angela
angela that's what it was yeah i didn't
yeah there you go tammy angela
hmm
i hope she has a friend named tammy she
can't stand when they were kids just
hated her mean to her on the bus and
angel's like ugh you would good job
and um so yeah in case you're wondering
that's the story of the show
um i read a lot kelly reads a lot
um james just makes music or i don't
know what you do listen to i got four
kids bro yeah kind of busy that's cool
yeah
me and kayla have four between us but
maybe you should have thought that
before maybe
you shaming me they can just cry it out
james while you're reading just let him
cry you read it well played read your
books jesus
all right uh what's next um let's see
what has wilco ever done to you not put
out a good record that's what they've
done
they've not put out a good record
listen the war on drugs incredible band
old rem incredible wilco is like if rem
and pearl jam had a weird sad child they
just sat in the room and made noise
like i feel like wilco gets in a room
and they go
and then they go oh let's make that an
analog and everyone goes
and then they all get their their
roland jazz master the finner jazz
masters and the roland's all jangled up
and i'm like let's jingle together
everybody and then wilco's like and the
colors bloom in our hearts everyone's
like oh i don't know what that means it
must be i don't know i'm not in it war
on drugs amazing rem incredible pearl
jams obviously protein they're the best
old sound garden yet
i don't know man
i just
there was that one that
one um even like the decemberists i mean
there's so many incredible bands like
that and the wilco is just like a mush
right in the middle
i've heard them compared to the white
stripes no jack black is extraordinary i
don't i don't get it james i can see
like your heart is is in tatters right
now help me i'm actually enjoying
hearing your opinion of them i i mean to
each his own i like them
what about them do you like
let's go through the list their
inability to write songs do you like
that
i'm not gonna be able to argue with you
if you're okay if you're this adamant
about it sorry okay no i like the
songwriting i think
he is um
like not a singer a crazy good singer
but i think the songwriting is good i
like the production like you talk about
the analog thing
sonically it's great
i would like kind of lump them in with
war on drugs even though wilco was
around way earlier yeah but i don't know
i feel like the war on drugs listen to a
bunch of wilco and they're like
we could do this and
write a song with a hook to it and have
a melody that would be cool and we could
all play somewhat same key curious how
many wilco records you've actually
listened to is almost none that's what
makes this so there you go okay so found
out i don't know any wilco music i'm
just seriously ranting about a band i
literally know nothing about i watched
the documentary on him once i wasn't
that impressed
i will go
they may be great that's the plot twist
i don't know any wilco songs i don't
listen to them i've been ranting about
something i know nothing about this
is the terror of the internet's good
people
yes i don't know i literally don't
before this i googled like wilco and it
was like kind of like rem and kind of
like
whatever and so i all that i just made
up
i was kind of impressed by your rant
until would i like them yeah
would you like them
i think so
give them a
chance all right number eight johnny
cash elvis or jim morrison
oh this is a thief
jim morrison
it's just morrison you got to go with
johnny cash on this what do you guys
think
johnny cash yeah
he's the only one i really like know his
music well enough to
comment on yeah oh man you should have
heard me talk about wilco a second ago
ah man all right uh number nine
um sammy hagar or david lee roth i've
seen them both it comes to like again
melodies songs
sammy hagar like actually being able to
sing when it comes to a show
there is no i mean daily roth dude
he's like 60 he's five and he's still
rocking spandex
like white spandex with like american
stars on the side i mean he gives zero
craps and he's flying around to trapeze
and stuff i mean that dude could put on
a [ __ ] yo
not the greatest singer in the world
it's okay that's all right as james said
not crazy good at singing
which is
latin for
not a good singer
um but that's what i think about them
all right uh tim how is rush not my
favorite
man
there are some rush fans out there who
are all into the rush so let's be very
clear
neil pert incredible
giddy lee incredible
alex incredible
they're good they're good
but they
his singing wasn't great and they sing
about like dragons and clouds and
whatnot like i didn't they're always
singing about flying and rainbows and
on the fountain steve like i don't know
i they they weren't my jam i do love
them my sister saw him unconsciously
they were incredible i never had to see
him live i should have um they are
extraordinary band they got some great
songs they are not my favorite
and when you're a kid again which most
of my memories are formed like they're
singing about clouds and dragons and
rainbows and then i got pantera that's
like respect and then i got metallica
that's like master like as for a
16 year old with no self-esteem i needed
that i needed some guys yelling and
saying like let's take on the world not
we're all flying through the
crowded skies on a red caterpillar does
that make sense
i don't know do you like rush
i like i mean i i sound all down on them
i think they're technically amazing no
not a fan i appreciate the music the
talent but i would rather dig my
eardrums out with a spoon
that's what you said that's the exact
thing you said when we had to listen
back to a couple of our podcasts
you said i appreciate that they're
i didn't even say that actually james
you rush fan
maybe uh rush is not happy with your
answer and they shut our screens off
behind you
is not a fan of what's going on back
here
um i
cannot stand rush i like some some prog
rock i like yes dream theater dude it's
the best but i uh rush i can't handle
dream theater best best best best all
right um number 11 what made you realize
you wanted to go into psychology
okay a couple of couple of thoughts here
the first one is i think i've talked
about this on the show my dad was
homicide detective and a swat hostage
negotiator in the city of houston so
he was always dealing in the lives of
other people and so i just had a
ringside seat and he's also worked with
local church worked with local youth
organizations so he was always dealing
with people's challenges
and so at a young age i was fascinated
by what would drive somebody to kill
somebody or what would drive somebody to
be an addict or why did that person
choose to get in a fight i wanted to
know how people worked i liked learning
how people worked and more importantly
like that's a research psychologist i
wanted to be able to help
and so
um i want to be an fbi when i was a
little kid and
that didn't work out and so i went to
college the ultimately the
i wanted to help people but i didn't
want to go to school for a hundred years
ultimately what switched was i was a
sophomore junior in college maybe junior
and i i mean i wish it was more
i wish it wasn't so it's almost
embarrassing i went and saw the movie
good will hunting
and i remember watching the interaction
robin williams character
shawna thinks his name and matt damon's
character
and
i mean matt damon's cool he's a genius
but i remember watching
robin williams
and i remember leaving that theater
saying
that's what i want to do
and i went and changed my major on
monday and it was the close
i had to take x number of psychology
courses over the next year and a half to
maybe two years and i'd hustle
and so i ended up with a humanities
undergrad degree because that was the
best way they could cobble together i
mean like dude you're already halfway
through your program
and so i ended up with enough psychology
courses that i could go to graduate
school i think you had to have 21 hours
or 18 hours something like that to go to
grad school but when i look at the arc
of my career
i liked the idea of the what my whole
goal in life was before i took this
crazy job was to be the guy behind every
behind closed doors
so when somebody was
working through hard things in their
life
they would call somebody and that person
would say i know a guy and i wanted to
be that guy no billboards no
advertisements i want to be the person
behind the person
and i wanted to not exist in the phone
book and not exist on the internet i
wanted some to be able to
see people and help
and
then i got a fancy job at a college and
so i took the quickest route i could go
and that was to get a phd in education
so i could be a college administrator i
want to be a college president for a
season
the further i got down that rabbit hole
the more my job was taken up whether it
was personnel issues or whether it was
student issues or whether it was student
family issues
was psychology psychology psychology i'm
gonna hurt myself my your child just
tried to kill themselves
uh we just got a divorce i need you to
tell our my child
um
i have to tell you that your job
performance isn't enough and oh my gosh
now you're curling the floor and you're
weeping or i've got to let you go and
how do i do that with dignity i've got
to fire you how do i do that with
dignity and let you retain your
respectability and we honor you in this
process so it was all about psychology
and it wasn't until i had my own
run in well i was just crippled by
anxiety i just my body said enough
that i became obsessed
from a from a research angle like what
is happening i want to know why this is
happening
and where is this heading and
so i started nickel and diming my way i
started taking class after class reading
book after book i just got obsessed with
it i think it was in 2010
um 2008 when i really went off the deep
end like i want to learn everything i
can about how the brain works and the
body works and the interaction between
nutrition and psychology and family of
origin and family systems and
mental health issues i wanted to know
all of it how all that works together
and in many ways it's gotten muddy or
muddier and in many ways it's gotten so
much clearer
um but all along i traced all the way
back to me being a child
and
the two big neon signs one is when
there's a people are hurting you go in
you go in i got that from my dad you
head in
and then the i think i talked about this
show too the second one is my mom
had some restraints on her just because
of our
just her
um upbringing that women didn't need to
go to college and so watching my mom at
age 40
go back to go to college the first time
and
in a way have an entire world shift and
change
and to see how does that happen and
what's the impact on family systems and
what's that impact on her and on
people like her and then on marginalized
community i just got obsessed with
psychology so i had a ringside seat to
it and then i had family experiences and
personal experiences that led me to it
then man i wish i wish i could give you
some great epiphany answer other than i
wouldn't saw goodwill hunting and i
remember leaving saying i want to do
that
and that's my journey with psychology
and now i have a radio show
[Music]
so great just like i drew it up who
knows it does say it does
man
follow what you love follow what you
love
work takes care of itself follow what
you love all right we'll be right back
on the dr john delaney show
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why because
they're committed to doing what's right
for you and that means walking you
through paperwork that's way over your
head that means making sure you get the
right mortgage that you can pay off as
soon as possible and they'll try to
upsell you a bunch of nonsense that's
going to hurt you down the road and most
importantly when you're making this big
life change you can actually
breathe because you've got an expert in
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple h
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane sweet
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we're back with our 200th
episode ama number three
here we go
all right number 12.
what was
jocko really like
that's a good question
um so i jocko was a part of an event i
was um a part of also we both were
speaking on the same bill and then i
ended up interviewing him for
an hour or so as a part of
on stage
um
here's a couple things about jocko
number one
he's an incredible human being
he is exactly
as you would imagine
what i mean by that is he was early he
was incredibly professional
he was super respectful and kind
he wanted minimal details sometimes you
work with you show up on these events
and you've got somebody ranting about
like
i wanted this kind of salmon and you got
me this kind of salmon
and it was very much
um
any special meals no thank you i'm good
it and it's this idea that if i get
somewhere and the food is something that
you all provided which is a gift
isn't um gonna be something i can eat or
i'm interested in eating or i choose to
eat then i'll choose too fast and
everything's gonna be great
and so it was very much what's the
timing to be where how much how long do
i need to go what's the setup and then i
will do an excellent job
and man behind closed doors you couldn't
ask for a kinder human he was nice he
was kind nothing like you get some guys
like that like flex in mexico none of
that at all
um
and then on stage man just world-class
just professional as could be i'll tell
you this though this is the one like big
epiphany i had so i just worked with
high profile high performing people
behind closed doors for years and years
and years
and so one of my goals is to always get
to
the humanity i don't care what your job
is i don't care what you do i don't care
whatever how much money you have blah
blah blah at the end of the day you're a
dad in the day you're a husband in a day
you're a
woman with a small child like you're a
person
and i always want to peel that back and
get there
and it was about halfway through my
interview with jocko on stage in front
of hundreds if not thousands of people
and i remember thinking to myself
oh
you're not like us
you
you operate in a different way
and not that it's unattainable but you
have worked really really hard to
automate some things in your mind
that i take for granted
that i argue with myself about you do
not have that argument anymore
um
i tend to over dramatize things and over
sensationalize you don't have that and
so that's the first time in my career
that i've sat next to somebody and said
oh you've leveled
you're you've leveled yourself in into a
different type of person than the rest
of us
and
a couple of things number one
um i left that and have not gone more
than one day skipping a workout except
when i got i got sick
um
i don't miss
and it's that it's a choice it's a
decision even if it's just one i can get
one like set in
i'm not gonna miss
and those aren't like because i gotta
keep going it's cause i'm just choosing
to
um my diet has gotten much more
intentional i've just gotten healthier
um
it was a good primer it was a good
reminder seeing him in the in the flesh
like
this is what it's just a daily decision
to just be different looks like and the
second thing i walked away with is thank
god they're people like him
as americans we kind of just walk around
in hope we think like yeah yeah those
guys are
it's impressive
i'm glad
i'm glad they exist and i'm glad they're
out there taking care of us in the
middle of the night we have no idea i'm
glad for that um so yeah jack was super
he's just he's different he's an
incredible guy and we're i just just
told me i'm going to be on an event with
him this upcoming year again and i look
forward to meeting him again he's a
great human being
um what's the favorite part of my job
uh public speaking is my favorite i
think it's the best thing i'm at i don't
know i think i'm better at that than
other things maybe maybe i'm not um and
then i like the radio show i think this
is fun i still can't believe we get paid
for this but this is fun
um
writing i like it but it kills me
um it takes my soul from me um and again
i just hit send on the big draft of book
it'll be out here in the spring but that
kills me um that's not the funnest part
it's the most necessary part i have to
do it but i don't i don't love it
um
i don't know i just like i don't know i
like talking with people for a living
that's what i do
i don't know what's your favorite part
of this job
when it's over
i think
yeah seeing something from like the
rough version or even talking about it
beforehand
and then
seeing the comments or feedback or
emails we get from people after it's
been published because sometimes the
span of time that happens between those
things is you kind of forgot that you
did something and then seeing what it
means to someone out there even if it's
just one person that's really cool oh we
got an email today i won't read it loud
i did an event i've done one event this
this fall that i thought didn't go well
i just it it was a strange event i was
talking about trauma and relationships
and it was i was booked at an event and
it was over lunch
and so here i am like on stage like the
lunch speaker and it's all like
it just it just was a strange vibe and
i'm there like talking about
relationships and trauma and then i can
just see some in the audience like
oh hey pass the broccoli please all
right hey can i have some iced tea it
was just a strange setup normally it's
like in a theater or something like that
and then today somebody wrote an amazing
email back to saying i happen to be in
that audience and here's what's my life
looks like now and so yeah those things
are just incredible that's that is the
favorite part like out of the side of
the mechanics
just that somehow somebody feels really
alone and they take one of these little
nuggets so they listen to somebody be
brave on the air when they call and then
they go do something brave i think
that's great
um let's see who's my dream show guest
all right let's see i wrote a couple
down here
um
jock i think i'm gonna have them on the
show this when we meet together i'm
gonna see if i can take a mobile unit
and we can meet up there i'd love to
have them on the show that'd be fun
i want to get an astros player i want to
talk to an astros player that would be
cool
they're not doing that
um
here's a segment that me and blake have
talked about which would be rad is so
many old rockers moved to nashville to
retire
my dream is
hashtag producer james make this happen
or kelly associate producer we can just
edge old man out and get this done
i want to have a segment where like once
every few weeks we have an old 80s metal
rocker we interview them
and then we get the acoustics out and we
play the song of the day which is an old
80s metal tune
and i think that would be incredible and
james you can play too
but no telecasters wouldn't that be
incredible oh you know i'm here for that
oh totally
yeah dude
i'm pulling out my acid-washed miniskirt
in my aquanet i will go buy some leather
pants it'll be amazing so that would be
dream
i mean just the guys here in town nelson
and slaughter and poison there's all
these guys who live here in town old
warrant old skid rogue i mean they it's
incredible who lives here um oh crew i
mean it's awesome and they would just
show up wearing makeup already because
that's how they live yes in their long
hair and their leather pants which is
every day they take the trash out
leather pants it'd be incredible have
you talked about how you have to wear
makeup you should talk about that i have
to wear makeup on this show that's not
my favorite part that's my least
favorite part of the show not a huge fan
but if the 80s metal guys are here we do
it together we can put eyeliner on with
them that'd be a great ball so good we
have like makeup tutorial
in a hair tees tutorial christy rachel
and you all do a combo show oh man it'd
be so great
yes we probably have to have lots of
edits it'd be great i'd love it um i'd
love to have somebody from the band
poison be on the show it'll just be
pretty rad
um peter tia he's just a guy that i have
a high respect for um
he's great mogadot esther perel
octavia butler is she's my favorite
sci-fi writer
um she's just oh she's incredible i'd
love to have her on here and then my
favorite poet in the world stephen
connell i'd love to have him on here too
just to chit chat he's he's pretty
amazing but i love i love spending time
with poets they're great i would say
that my favorite guest though this is
gonna sound so cheesy and lame
i love talking to regular people i i
there's a million podcasts where they
just interview other famous people and
then they have famous people that they
interview and it's just like this big
incestuous circle they just loop-de-loop
like hey you be on my back i still be on
yours i just talking to regular people
who are just trying to figure out life
because i'm just a regular guy trying to
figure out life too and i like just
walking along i leave this show feeling
a little less alone
and so i don't know i i don't there's
not a lot of podcasts with people just
talking to
i don't know
just folks like you and me so i love
that like y'all end up being my favorite
guests by far i just love it so if we
can get the 80s metal thing that would
be do
but that's it so that's the questions
y'all got that's it this time this is a
short one
so we have we each have one more that
we're going to throw
so mine is
what is one thing that you
always talk about that you're not good
at yourself like one thing that you
preach people to do that you're not the
best at the way you're asking that is
you have you have an idea what do you
think the idea i i genuinely don't i
just i'm curious because somebody like
whether it's you or dave or somebody
here you're always telling people like
ideal like the stuff that they should be
doing but everybody has you know a weak
area of what even the stuff that they
tell people to do they have a hard time
with so three you talk about some of
that weakest areas i have right now are
i
have a really heavy anxiety trigger when
it comes to
money
when it comes to making enough money to
saving enough money and how retirement
systems work
and i think it's because i don't
understand how they work i get the i get
how a mutual fund works in theory
i feel beholden to a machine that is so
big and so unwieldy and so off the
tracks that it holds my grandkids
ability to eat or my children's
abilities so
i struggle with that um and so here
working with dave
like with dave ramsey you'd think man we
all just got their money stuffed down
like i struggle with that um second one
is
i tell everybody not to take things
personal from their kids and that's i
struggle with that like my kids say
things then i i take it personal
um and i've gotta constantly remind
myself to separate myself out from that
and i don't want to ever become a robot
either so i always want to be a little
bit thin skinned i want things to
penetrate and get them hard a little bit
and then i got to go act and then the
third thing is i'm trying man but i
started like would you stop make a
decision
i just got to be better about being late
like just being on time and like i gotta
i just gotta be better about it
and you've gotten a lot better on the
show i'm trying yeah you really have you
can tell i'm trying but it and it makes
for a better show it makes for a better
everything and so
it's really living a different life and
that's i don't know why that's so hard
for me um
it's that imaginary time and times i saw
a meme the other day that said it was
like a picture of i don't know some
cartoon character sprinting and i just
said me leaving my house at 8 15 hoping
to get to work at eight and that was me
that is me every single day so
um timeliness those are the three things
i struggle with the most and then man i
just love eating garbage sometimes
it good question
what about you okay so i struggle with
the time management thing too so you're
not alone in that
um okay i actually have two one's really
simple
best hair from our metal days
what who had it oh man
i mean i don't know that you could
compete with nelson
those two blond-haired guys i know no
i'll see uh uh that's your opinion and
then nikki's hair was pretty great
okay who's your th who do you think it
was i would have probably gone with tom
kiefer from cinderella
because it was just big yeah and
spectacular he lives here in franklin i
know i'll have him on his show i know he
does and sing heartbreak station
together oh my gosh
yeah window
all right second question
so
you know i love my murder podcasts and
all that and of course i think growing
up as the child of a homicide detective
would be like oh my god amazing
but i have a feeling that it's not as
amazing as i think it would be so
what are some things as
growing up as the son of a homicide
detective how
how did that impact your life is you
know your teen years
oh
my teen years
those teenagers weren't great
but i listened to a lot of pantera and
slayer so i'm sure that didn't help
either
um i
um let me see all that
so
i think the big one is the default
setting and i may have talked about that
on the show but when you're a homicide
detective you deal with a hundred
percent of your work day is dealing with
things that never happen
like none of us will ever know anybody
that's murdered with an axe
or that they were just getting out of
their car at gas station and somebody
came and shot him 42 times we don't know
anybody we hear about that story that
happens in north carolina whatever
when you're a homicide detective
all day every day that's all you deal
with is that
and so it skews your
sense of reality
and every dark alley becomes a place
where not you could you will get
murdered
or like so or every interaction he could
have a gun like he's probably not gonna
have a gun
and
but it could because that's what you
deal with all day
um and so
i i have a bent towards
this
strange
i i've got a strange psychology in
i just think everything's gonna work out
fine
because if it doesn't help me dead like
it's a weird like man i'll be i'll be
dead
and so i have this strange optimism
about it'll be fine we'll figure it out
and it's all coming down
and i think that as a as a young kid
thinking through 18 steps ahead all the
time was exhausting and a teenager's
brain can't do that but i was always
trying to compute that and it made me
nuts ultimately and made me just angry
all the time and when you're 17 you know
everything when you're 15 you know
everything and you have a homicide
detective who actually does know a lot
and he's a hostage negotiator so his job
is talking people out of killing
themselves for a living and so you can't
win an argument so that was hard that
was hard hard
the benefit though is
like man i learned a lot about how the
world worked at a young age and i
wouldn't trade that for anything and i
had my dad was he was pretty open with
me about how the world works and um
that was that was a blessing it was cool
that was pretty cool but yeah man things
got
it was
it took me a while my wife still to this
day she's like we got we're good right
now we could we got enough and she'll
say that just gently and i'll say okay
cool because that guy's still in there
like it's all gonna come
you know what i mean who knows i do
think that that used to be captive to a
small group of people who dealt in that
for a living
and i do think with like law order svu
and all the shows and all the podcasts i
think that sentiment has spread to
everybody that we're all running around
going it's all coming down
and that used to not be the case
oh i totally agree because i mean you
know i watch all that stuff and i listen
to it and i read it and i see it
everywhere to me is
you know where somebody's going to get
murdered or accosted or taken but it's
different than that it is where
someone's getting murdered but it also
it i think it shifts the default setting
to
they just say that because they're lazy
they just do that because they're this
it's a bent on human nature that i
think's a little bit off
we used to just think i think i did that
they must be what it's just skewed our
it's just bent our default setting i
think a little bit it has for me i mean
if not for you you may think the best of
everyone still
i don't think so
and now
um but to me it's the difference between
james
hit that button
oh that's the wrong button man
like oh man james got a lot going on or
james incompetent or james is always
just trying to screw this show up
because it's not as important as but
it's probably somewhere in the middle
and that's you you're just
jangling away at your fender like hey
guys let's just stay in the middle
listen to wilson wilco
unbelievable
we're on drugs
check them out you know they're coming
to the ryman
are you going
i'm not i saw them a couple years back
and i like them but there's only so much
i can take of 15-minute guitar solos of
every song i can see that yeah
but they're great are they good live
i'm not going
i texted blake the other night and i was
like dude
you're gonna go and he's like um number
one we bought tickets to that show like
nine months ago cool and there's a whole
group of us going we'll get you next
time and it sold out for like
six months so
thanks john anyway it's cool all right
that's it man that's it
episode 200
no confetti or anything but it's cool
we'll put it in post me and my
[Laughter]
me and my members only jacket
i feel like i'm gonna be a west side
story after this is over
anyway all right so song of the day this
is from
james
okay so you love the smiths what what's
your relationship with him you don't
like morrissey would you like to smith's
oh man um it's a recent i didn't get
into them until recently and i i just
like made a playlist of my favorite
songs because there's not any certain
album that i like love that album
um and i think
i think morrissey is just really funny
and whiny sometimes he's i just have a
love-hate relationship with with him but
i think he's a clever writer and he's
yeah he's very clever and just the
tongue-in-cheek is really really funny i
love johnny marr guitar player talk
about jangle he's the jingle jingle's
all the way yeah but i thought the song
fit well
i love i love it thanks man from the
smiths
from the louder than bombs album
oh i see what you did there james
the song is called ask
no just like the ama all right i see
what you did there
that's cute man
the smiths ask the song goes like this
shyness is nice and shyness can stop you
from doing all the things in life you'd
like to
shyness is nice
and shyness
can stop you from doing all the things
in life you'd like to yes they repeat
that twice
so if there's something you'd like to
try if there's something you'd like to
try ask me i won't say no how could i
sounds like dr seuss
coinness is nice
coinas can stop you from saying all the
things in life you'd like to so if
there's something you'd like to try if
there's something you'd like to try ask
me i won't say no
how could i
james
what's so funny
it really does sound like dr seuss it
does
maybe morrissey is dr seuss
and more plot twists right here on the
dr john dolone's show